it's Thor versus a helicopter in a
jaw-dropping scene that scared actor
Chris Hemsworth here's why the stunt
shook the Marvel star to his core making
an action film is hard work fights must
be painstakingly choreographed to avoid
stray punches doing damage stunts must
be carefully prepared for and every
person on the set must be protected
against explosives High Falls or weapons
used in a scene with all of that in mind
can anyone really blame Chris Hemsworth
for feeling a little scared about
performing his own stunts for extraction
too speaking with the Associated Press
in June on the red carpet for the
extraction 2 premiere Hemsworth admitted
that he tries to stay cognizant to the
danger inherent in doing this type of
acting yet a sphere of one scene in
particular was very real he told the AP
there's always risk going into those
scenes that said the one that scared me
the most was being on top of a moving
train that was going 40 miles an hour
and having a helicopter 20 feet in front
of me flying backwards that sequence was
one of the toughest what Hemsworth fails
to mention is that the action sequence
in question was also filmed during
Sub-Zero temperatures it sounds like
quite a complicated piece of action
choreography to commit to film so why
does the actor choose to perform his own
stunts he explained that turning out a
believable product is important to him
telling the AP this is real you know
we're sweating we're anxious we're
nervous we're intimidated and that's
what's being captured Hemsworth is
definitely selling his abilities short
extraction 2 director Sam Hargrave who
also brought the first film to life
opened up to Games Radar about how the
Thor actor is pushed to his limit with
the Netflix release telling the outlet
the crazy thing is he's right there with
you and never backs away from a
challenge while standing atop a speeding
train as a helicopter is chasing after
you is surely a terrifying thought so is
being lit on fire the extraction 2
director continued by pointing out how
the film's headlining action set piece a
21-minute long continuous sequence
starts off with the Tyler rake actor
becoming one with fire Hargrave said we
lit him on fire CGI just doesn't look
the same it doesn't have the same feel
so he was like yeah light me up how many
times did Hemsworth find himself on fire
seven or eight times according to the
director bar grave it's important that
audiences find the action and extraction
to authentic echoing Hemsworth's
comments about creating a product that's
believable he added part of the DNA of
this franchise is real people doing real
action on real locations stylistically
audiences can tell the difference when
you're in front of a blue screen versus
being out there for real I was strapped
to or moving on top of a speeding train
while a real helicopter was Landing
three feet from me it's no surprise that
Hargrave and Hemsworth are on the same
page when it comes to the film's action
it's not work both creatives are
producers on the Netflix flick now
jaw-dropping helicopter stunt isn't the
only piece of action choreography
Hemsworth performed for extraction too
in fact the entire sequence is part of
the film's lengthy one take action
sequence which sees his character
jumping from set piece to set piece
Hemsworth discussed the sequence with
hollywoodlife saying that he took part
in it himself I feel like everything I'd
done in the last 10 years kind of led to
that point it was exhausting the
sequence is certainly worth the price of
admission or Netflix subscription alone
with Looper critic Aleister Ryder
calling it 20 minutes of ingeniously
executed action that starts off as a
prison break that quickly escalates into
a bombastic Chase is definitely one of
Hemsworth's finest moments as Tyler rake
that's not to say Hemsworth performs all
of his characters Mighty Feats of
Strength even with the assistance of CGI
Bobby Holland Hanton the actor's regular
stunt man has stepped in for Hemsworth
on numerous occasions starting with Thor
the Dark World aside from performing
stunt work in all of Hemsworth's
subsequent Marvel films Hansen has also
doubled for him in both extraction films
bad times at the El Royale the Huntsman
Winter's war and in the heart of the Sea
The Working relationship between Hanton
and Hemsworth has also resulted in a
private Boon from their professional
connection the two men have fostered a
friendship that has spanned a decade in
fact the duo were so close that
according to an op-ed written by Hanton
for Newsweek in 2021 Hemsworth's mother
refers to Hampton as her fourth son
thank you
[Music]